hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
hope you've all been doing well since
its founding in 2009
by two former yahoo employees brian
acton
and jan comb whatsapp has been one of
the principal places to message family
and friends across the globe
it enjoys more popularity outside of the
united states with over 2 billion users
worldwide
mostly in latin america india europe and
many african nations
recently people have been fleeing from
the service after it was announced that
a new update will be making the
messaging app
share data with facebook if users don't
accept the new terms of the update
they'll no longer be able to use the app
so is it time for whatsapp users to run
for the hills is it all over let's try
and take a balanced look at this
you are watching cold fusion tv
2014 whatsapp was bought by facebook
facebook has bought the mobile messaging
service whatsapp
for 19 billion dollars in cash in stock
at the time 8 million users fled to the
rival
app telegram and the buyout was called
quote
a 911 for the internet by techcrunch
despite facebook's ownership whatsapp
was still seen as a privacy focused
service since 2014 its developers built
state-of-the-art
end-to-end encryption into the app they
made use of an open source protocol
that could be independently verified
with this latest privacy update user
data can be shared with facebook and any
of its other companies it owns
so what's happening those who don't
accept the revamp privacy policy by
february 8
will no longer be able to use the app so
what data is being shared with facebook
and instagram
the shared data is quote profile name
profile picture ip address battery level
signal strength app version browser
information
mobile network connection information
phone number mobile operator isp
language time zone device operations
information
including identifiers unique to facebook
company products
associated with the same device or
account end quote
according to whatsapp the purpose of
this is to quote
offer integrations across facebook
company products which also includes
instagram and messenger
in other words to target adverts to you
for example when you share a link of a
product like a new phone you're
interested in or a smart speaker
to a friend or family member in a
whatsapp message
whatsapp can share their info to other
facebook companies to display targeted
ads to you on instagram or facebook
the policy also notes that even after
deleting the app
some data will remain with the company
the new policy is so aggressive that it
doesn't apply in the eu
because it violates gdpr laws
it's interesting to note that in 2019 on
their company website
whatsapp stated that privacy was in
their dna
but in 2020 this statement was removed
to many users it seems like whatsapp is
no longer a privacy focused product
[Music]
signal and telegram messaging apps are
now seeing a sudden increase in demand
after the news broke on social media
signals popularity shot up even further
after it was endorsed by elon musk
more than a hundred thousand users
installed signal on apple's app store
and the google play store
and in just two days following the news
telegram picked up 2.2 million downloads
new installs for whatsapp fell 11 in the
first seven days of 2021
compared with the prior week but it
should be noted that a singular data
point
isn't a trend
[Music]
while some media outlets are claiming
that the sky is falling
whatsapp has actually been sharing user
information and metadata with facebook
since 2016.
in fact the european commission would
find facebook for being misleading
during
its 2014 takeover of whatsapp facebook
at the time said that it quote
would be technically impossible to
automatically combine user information
from facebook and whatsapp
end quote but in 2016 they did
just that facebook's explanation for the
misleading statements in their filing
was simply that it was quote not
intentional
in addition facebook also promised to
keep whatsapp as a standalone product
but this promise too was broken back in
2016
they offered existing users 30 days to
opt out of the data sharing with
facebook
if you chose to opt out at that time
whatsapp would continue to honour that
choice
this opt out feature has been long gone
and all new users
after this time automatically had their
data shared with facebook
but according to wired the most recent
privacy policy changes
do not actually impact whatsapp's
existing practices or behavior around
data sharing with facebook
the policy update was simply a
clarification on how user data was
shared
so the buzz on the internet is mostly an
overreaction
since this has been going on since 2016.
but that being said
the amount of data whatsapp can collect
and share about you
and the fact that it's been consistently
sharing this with facebook is still
concerning
people aren't willing to pay for all
content on the internet and the way that
they can pay for it without paying for
it with cash
is by looking at ads or being subjected
to ads
isn't everybody better off if the ads
are targeted to the interests of the
individual that's the the kind of
talking point that is a common refrain
somebody has to pay for uh for content
to be produced
entertainment or or information online
at the same time we have to think really
carefully about
what it is that we're giving up when
we're surrendering our privacy
anyone who has the technical capacity to
can track whatever you do
on the internet combine that with any
other data sources that they can acquire
about you from credit card companies
cell phone provider anywhere else
and just say that you can do whatever
you want within that
with that data as long as you can make
it happen it's a digital
infrastructure that makes targeted
advertising possible
that same infrastructure can be used
just as easily to sell sneakers
as you say as it can to propagate
disinformation
uh it can be spreading lies about uh
entire ethnic groups and encouraging
people to harm them and that's
something that's been good going on in
myanmar notably via facebook
the merger of facebook and whatsapp was
controversial within the whatsapp
company
and it may have contributed to the
departure of both whatsapp's co-founders
in late 2017
and 2018 respectively one of whom went
on to work on signal
though the new whatsapp privacy policy
doesn't change whatsapp's behavior since
2016 it can be a reminder
that a lot of the apps that we use for
free cost nothing because it's in fact
us that are being sold to product
advertisers
fortunately for users there's some great
alternative privacy focused messaging
apps
like telegram or signal so what do you
guys think
are you going to switch to alternatives
like telegram or signal or
are you okay with targeted advertising
feel free to discuss below
so thanks for watching the whole way
through this episode my name is dagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion
and i'll catch you again soon for the
next video next time
we'll take a look at the rise and fall
of intel in a two-part video series
part one should be coming soon cheers
guys
have a good one
[Music]
is
[Music]
you